así aterrizaban kazajistán da cápsula
rusa soyuz action y en su interior dos
cosmonautas rusos y un astronauta
estadounidense
un gesto simbólico de unión que difiere
de las crecientes tensiones en la tierra
los tripulantes partieron de la estación
espacial internacional el estadounidense
vandehei que completaba su segunda
misión en la estación espacial registró
un récord para eeuu de trescientos
cincuenta y cinco días consecutivos en
órbita entre los cosmonautas rusos tu
brazo completó su primer viaje y
shkaplerov ha estado ocupando la función
de comandante en la estación espacial
internacional
así se despedía el martes de sus
compañeros
la gente tiene problemas en la tierra en
la órbita somos como somos una
tripulación y creo que la estación
espacial internacional es un símbolo de
amistad y cooperación y un símbolo para
la futura exploración del espacio
símbolo future of exploration space
chief of thrones ayuso que pasa al mando
en la comandancia al estadounidense
thomas mars words
antón es un honor y un privilegio
aceptar el mando de la estación espacial
con esta asociación internacional y este
legado en los vuelos espaciales en space
white
este vuelo conjunto ha sido observado de
cerca la invasión de rusia ucrania del
24 de febrero y las posteriores
sanciones occidentales han levantado las
especulaciones de que esta cooperación
espacial de larga data esté en riesgo
sin embargo por el momento trabajan de
forma profesional e incluso astronautas
y cosmonautas contrastan con sus buenas
relaciones los enfrentamientos en la
tierra